dies ist das letzte bekannte Bild
brigosch ins aus einem Video Ort
unbekannt wie so oft er spricht über
einen Einsatz in Afrika nun soll er tot
sein abgestürzt als einer von 10
Passagieren auf einem Flug von Moskau
nach St Petersburg in der Region wer
soll die Ambra Legacy vom Himmel
gefallen sein wie diese Bilder aus dem
Internet belegen sollen das brigosh ihn
tot ist bestätigen russische Behörden
und die wagnergruppe gleichermaßen
Trümmer und tote an der Absturzstelle
auch Wagner Gründer die Mitri utkin soll
in der Maschine gewesen sein
priorchin der unberechenbare vor knapp
zwei Monaten Zettel der mit seinen
Wagner seltenen einen Putsch gegen Putin
an und unterliegt Belarus nimmt ihn auf
behauptet jedenfalls der dortige gemacht
habe zuvor gelangten Panzer bis nach
wördernich der Weg nach Moskau schien
frei die genauen Umstände warum brigoch
in seine Söldner damals stoppte nicht
bekannt bekannt hingegen seine skurrilen
Auftritte im Kampf vom bachmut Spielen
seine selten eine wichtige Rolle doch
der Chef sieht sie als Kanonenfutter
verheizt was ich sonst keiner traut
rigoschin wütet gegen Putins
Militärführung und damit auch gegen ihn
und jetzt hört gut zu dir Arschlöcher
das sind Väter das sind Söhne und diese
Ärsche die uns keine Munition geben
die sollen in der Hölle schmoren
Soldaten und nutzt den Moment zum
Nachtreten
in bachmut kämpften wir nicht nur gegen
die Streitkräfte der Ukraine sondern
auch gegen die russische Bürokratie die
uns Stein in den Weg legte der
US-Präsident derzeit als Wahlkämpfer
unterwegs von Reportern um ein Statement
gebeten
ich weiß nicht genau was passiert ist
aber ich bin nicht überrascht es
passiert nicht viel in Russland ohne das
Putin dahinter steckt der Absturz
gregorschins war sein Fehler von
Menschen oder Material oder mach es
Putins später Rache an seinem
Widersacher der zu weit ging es gibt
viele Fragen und kommen Antworten
womöglich wird das auch so bleiben
ja und wie die Umstände des Absturzes
des Jets von wagner-chef bregosch in
einzuschätzen sind darüber haben wir mit
unserem moskau-korrespondenten Armin
Körper eben in der Sendung gesprochen
hier noch mal seine Einschätzung
[Musik]
natürlich gibt dieses Ereignis Raum für
Spekulationen es wird hier immer wieder
darauf hingewiesen dass pregoschin
eigentlich fast nie in die Maschine
gestiegen ist auf deren Passagierliste
erstaunt stellt sich auch die Frage dass
die sehr schnell die Meldungen kamen die
Leiche sei bereits identifiziert sie
identifiziert Entschuldigung sei unter
den Toten das ging viel zu schnell als
dass es da schon eine genetische
Untersuchung oder sowas hätte gegeben
haben können also Fakt ist es wird hier
keine Untersuchung geben und kein
Ergebnis geben das für uns und nach
unseren Standards irgendwie
nachvollziehbar ist